[Musik]
Benedikt XVI ist tot der deutsche der
emeritierte Papst ist heute früh um 9:34
Uhr im Alter von 95 Jahren im Vatikan
gestorben seit Tagen war bekannt dass es
schlecht steht um die Gesundheit von
Josef Ratzinger im
jahresschlussgottesdienst im Petersdom
würdigte Papst franziskus am Abend
seinen Vorgänger mit diesen Worten
[Musik]
mit Ergriffenheit erinnern wir uns an
seine so edle so sanfte Person und wir
empfinden so viel Dankbarkeit in unseren
Herzen Dankbarkeit gegenüber Gott dass
er ihn der Kirche und der Welt geschenkt
hat und Dankbarkeit gegenüber ihm für
all das Gute dass er vollbracht hat
in seiner Heimat in Bayern mischen sich
in die allgemeine Trauer heute auch
kritische Töne
ich bin auch betroffen gerade hier in
München verbindet viel in der Nähe des
Doms verbindet viel mit ihm der arme
Mann hat seine Seelenruhe verdient er
ist 95 Jahre er hat seine Lebensleistung
vollbracht und jetzt sei eben diese Ruhe
gegönnt und ich hoffe dass er oben gut
aufgenommen wird er war Hirte der Kirche
von München Freising hier und es ist es
tut mir schon sehr weh sehr konservativ
natürlich also er war ja sehr umstritten
jetzt mit den ganzen
missbrauchskandalen hat auch nicht für
ihn gesprochen sicherlich gibt's da
verschiedene Dinge die sehr Lasten
nachwirken über diesen Tod hinaus
Stimmen von der Straße eingefangen am
Todestag von Benedikt dem 16 und damit
guten Abend und herzlich willkommen zu
diesem ZDF Spezial acht Jahre lang war
Benedikt das Oberhaupt der katholischen
Kirche gemessen an seinem unmittelbaren
Vorgänger dem polnischen Papst Johannes
Paul II ist das sicher nicht viel aber
Josef Ratzinger war bei seiner Wahl eben
auch schon 78 Jahre alt und so zeichnete
sich bereits damals ab dass der deutsche
er ein übergangspaps werden würde
dennoch er hat den Kurs seiner Kirche
geprägt und mit seinem Rücktritt
schließlich Kirchengeschichte
geschrieben
seiner oberbayerischen Heimat war Josef
Aloisius Ratzinger ein Leben lang
verbunden
in Marktl am Inn ist er am Karsamstag
1927 zur Welt gekommen sein Geburtshaus
steht dort noch heute wie damals als er
mit seinen älteren Geschwistern Georg
und Maria seine früheste Kindheit erlebt
seine Mutter war Köchin der Vater
Jean-Marie Meister ein gestrenger aber
gerechter Mann der Ratzingers klares
Weltbild von Gut und Böse prägte wegen
des Berufs des Vaters muss die Familie
oft umziehen und obwohl das Geld knapp
war schickten die Eltern beide Brüder
auf das Herzen bischöfliche
Studienseminar nach Traunstein
im Zweiten Weltkrieg war er Hitlerjunge
Flakhelfer zum Schluss Geräte als
infanteriesoldat in amerikanische
Gefangenschaft
Priesterweihe 1951 in München nachdem
der Junge Josef Ratzinger erst sein
Abitur in Traunstein nachgeholt hatte
sobald es die Nachkriegswirren erlaubten
in seinem Wunschstudium der katholischen
Theologie bewies er früh besonderes
Talent in den Geisteswissenschaften
während des Zweiten Vatikanischen
Konzils Anfang der 1960er Jahre holt ihn
der Kölner Erzbischof Kardinal Frings
als konzilsberater
der Junge Ratzinger schreibt ihm eine
Brandrede gegen die Missstände im
heiligen Offizium geradezu revolutionär
und Aufsehen erregend für die damalige
Zeit
seine akademische Laufbahn führt ihn
nach Freising Bonn und Tübingen
1957 habilitiert er an der Münchner
Ludwig-Maximilian-Universität
1969 erhält er einen Ruf an die
Universität Regensburg die Hauptstadt in
der Oberpfalz wird seine Wahlheimat und
sein akademisches zu Hause dort lehrt er
docmatik und dokumen Geschichte der
Theologe der acht Sprachen beherrscht
macht sich bald einen Namen weil er
gegen die Gefährdung des Glaubens kämpft
und versucht die christliche Botschaft
vor Beliebigkeit zu bewahren im März
1977 wird Ratzinger Erzbischof von
München und Freising nur einen Monat
später er nennt ihn Papst Paul der
sechste zum Kardinal
in diese Zeit fehlt der später gegen ihn
erhobene Vorwurf er habe einen
pädophilen Priester geduldet der sich
immer wieder das Kindesmissbrauchs
schuldig gemacht hatte in Bistum München
bleibt der drei Jahre Papst Johannes
Paul II holte ihn wegen seiner
außergewöhnlichen Begabung als
Kirchenlehrer und glaubenshüter nach Rom
das Verhältnis zwischen dem polnischen
Papst und dem Kardinal aus Bayern ist
von tiefem Vertrauen geprägt Ratzinger
übernimmt die Schlüsselstellung des
perfekten der Glaubenskongregation
weil er bei den Themen des menschlichen
Lebens Familie Homosexualität und
Befreiungstheologie konservative
Positionen vertritt und als treibende
Kraft hinter dem Papst gilt kommt er in
den Hof eines ideologischen Hardliners
nach dem Tod von Johannes Paul dem
zweiten sehen viele in Ratzinger den
logischen Nachfolger auf dem Stuhl Petri
nach nur vier Wahlgängen wird er am 19
April 2005 Papst Benedikt der 16
ja und vor allem über die Jahre die dann
folgten und auch die katholische Kirche
in Deutschland geprägt haben wollen wir
jetzt sprechen mit dem Vorsitzenden der
Deutschen Bischofskonferenz dem
Limburger Bischof Georg betzing guten
Abend ich grüße Sie
ich grüße Sie Herr Bischof mit welchen
Gedanken Gefühlen haben sie die
Nachricht vom Tode Benedikt heute
aufgenommen
ja wir waren ja vorbereitet seitdem er
Mittwoch Papst franziskus schon
angedeutet habe hatte Papst Benedikt ist
schwer krank das bedeutet der er ist auf
dem letzten irdischen weg und deshalb
hat die Nachricht heute uns ja in
vorbereiteterweise getroffen und und
dennoch stimmt sie traurig ein Mann der
mit 95 Jahren in gesegneten Alter
gestorben ist die Kirche so stark
geprägt hat wie sie es ja gerade in
diesem Bericht auch deutlich gemacht
haben
drei Mal hat Benedikt ja in seiner
Amtszeit sein Heimatland besucht welche
Spuren hinterlässt der in der
katholischen Kirche in Deutschland
ich erinnerte daran bei seiner Wahl hieß
es wir sind Papst die Begeisterung war
riesig dass nach Jahrhunderten wieder
ein deutscher Papst geworden ist diese
Begeisterung hat natürlich mit der Zeit
irgendwo abgeäppt denn wir haben uns
nicht leicht getan als Landsleute mit
diesem Papst schon als er perfekt der
Glaubenskongregation war und Papst
Benedikt hat es uns auch nicht leicht
gemacht dadurch dass er das Evangelium
verkündet hat ob gelegen oder ungelegen
aber die Besuche hier in seiner Heimat
zum Weltjugendtag 2005 wo Millionen
junge Menschen da waren dann wieder 2006
seine bayerische Heimat und noch einmal
2011 das waren
Besuche mit grundlegenden Botschaften
nicht nur in die Kirche hinein sondern
auch in unseren Staat ich erinnere auch
an die Reden im Bundestag und den
Regensburg und vor allem er hat bei
diesen Besuchen deutlich gemacht der
Missbrauch muss auf den Tisch er hat
sich mit Betroffenen getroffen hat ihnen
zugehört hat ihre Anliegen aufgenommen
und das sollten wir Bedenken auch dann
wenn ja angesichts des missvers
Gutachten in München auch Fehler
deutlich geworden sind er hat sich bei
den Betroffenen entschuldigt er hat um
Verzeihung begeht gebeten Fragen sind
offen geblieben ein Thema bei dem wir
bleiben werden und das sicherlich zu
einem vollständigen Lebensbild von
Benedikt im 16 gehört Bischof betting
danke dass ihr uns heute Abend für
dieses Gespräch zur Verfügung stehen und
ihnen noch einen guten Jahresausklang
danke
ja bleiben wir ein bisschen beim Thema
missbrauche die Ergebnisse des Münchner
Gutachtens werfen ja tatsächlich einen
Schatten auf Josef Ratzinger als Papst
und seine frühere Rolle als Münchner
Erzbischof dass er gegenüber den
Gutachtern in mindestens einem Punkt die
Unwahrheit gesagt hat machte die Sache
nur noch schlimmer trotzdem Benedikt
Umgang mit dem Geschirr des sexuellen
Missbrauchs in der katholischen Kirche
ist vielschichtig Rita döbbe über einen
schwieriges Kapitel
Papst Benedikt und das Thema Missbrauch
ein Komplex der bis zu seinem Tod Fragen
aufwarf so ging es zum Beispiel auch in
einer missbrauchstudie des Erzbistums
München Freising im Januar 2022 um die
Zeit des damaligen Erzbischofs von
München Josef Ratzinger das späteren
Papstes Benedikt die Studie bescheinigt
ihm Unglaubwürdigkeit bezeichnet sein
Verhalten als Verantwortlicher im Jahr
1980 Kritik würdig er habe sich nicht
für die Leiden der Opfer interessiert
benedikt der 16 äußerte sich daraufhin
erneut
ich habe in der katholischen Kirche
große Verantwortung getragen umso größer
ist mein Schmerz über die Vergehen und
Fehler die in meinen Amtszeiten und an
den betreffenden Orten geschehen sind
als Papst geht Benedikt XVI strenger als
andere im Kampf gegen Missbrauch vor er
sucht als erster Papst die Begegnung mit
den Betroffenen und bewertet den
Missbrauchskandal in der katholischen
Kirche nicht als Schmutzkampagne der
sekulären Medien sondern als ein Problem
der Kirche selbst
er fordert Hilfe für die Opfer und harte
Strafen für die Täter auf seine
Anordnung hin werden die kirchlichen
Normen verschärft beim internationalen
Priester Treffen im Juni 2010 in Rom
bittet benedikt der 16 öffentlich um
Vergebung
auch wir bitten Gott und die betroffenen
Menschen inständig um Vergebung und
versprechen zugleich dass wir alles tun
wollen um solchen Missbrauch nicht
wieder vorkommt zu lassen
doch als emeritierter Papst wiederum
sorgt er für Irritationen er
veröffentlicht einen Text zu den
Ursachen des Missbrauchs und der Kirche
und macht darin die 68er und die
sexuelle Befreiung verantwortlich die
völlige sexuelle Freiheit die keine
Normen mehr zuließ habe dazu geführt
dass auch Pädophilie als erlaubt und
angemessen galt heißt es darin das Echo
darauf verheerend nicht nur wegen seines
Handelns als Erzbischof sehen in viele
in der Pflicht auch als perfekt und
Papst habe er nicht entschlossen genug
gehandelt dafür solle er persönlich
Verantwortung übernehmen in seiner
jüngsten Erklärung vom Februar 2022
spricht er zwar von Verantwortung der
Kirche doch zur persönlichen
Verantwortung sagt er nichts
und auch darüber müssen wir am heutigen
Todestag sprechen und zwar mit dem
Mitbegründer und Sprecher der
Betroffenen Initiative eckiger Tisch
guten Abend Herr Katsch
schönen guten Abend wo sehen Sie denn
wenn wir jetzt mal aufgreifen was im
Beitrag gesagt wurde Josef Ratzingers
größtes Versäumnis im Umgang mit Fällen
sexuellen Missbrauchs in der
katholischen Kirche
ja das ist heute Abend eine schwierige
Erinnerung ein schwieriger Rückblick für
Betroffener sexualisierter Gewalt von
Kindesmissbrauch in der Kindheit und
Jugend
weil Josef Ratzinger
Papst Benedikt wie kaum ein anderer
dieses System
katholische Kirche dem sie zum Opfer
gefallen sind dem ich auch zum Opfer
gefallen bin verkörpert hat und
die Einsicht dass es sich eben nicht um
bedauerliche Einzelfälle sondern
tatsächlich um ein systemisches Versagen
seiner Kirche handelte mit systemischen
Ursachen dazu ist er leider nie
vorgedrungen das hat er nicht
zugelassen und das ist sozusagen über
alles gesehen jenseits der
konkreten Dinge
sein seine Schuld oder seine Last und
gehört zur ganzen Wahrheit an diesem Tag
aber auch dass Josef Ratzinger als Papst
kirchliche Normen verschärft hat dass er
hunderte Kleriker in den leinenstand
versetzt hat also praktisch mit
Berufsverbot belegt sind das Maßnahmen
die sie als Betroffener heute würdigen
können
wir haben gerade kurz Bilder gesehen am
Ende des Beitrages von einer
Demonstration von Betroffenen aus aller
Welt in Rom 2019 bei den
missbrauchsgipfel den
franziskusveranstaltet hat und da ging
es um diese Politik der null Toleranz
und genau das hat er eben nicht in
seiner Amtszeit auf den Weg gebracht und
das beklagen wir auch bis heute noch das
ist die genau nicht gibt es sind viele
Priester entlassen worden aber es sind
viele tausend andere Täter eben nach wie
vor im Schoße der Kirche
aufgehoben worden und der eingangs
erwähnte Fall des Pfarrers hullermann
aus München ist ja der
Schlafende Beweis gewesen auch gegen ihn
als Erzbischof da ist ein Täter wieder
ins Amt gekommen hat über Jahrzehnte
weiterhin Kinder missbrauchen konnte
können weil die Kirche ebenso nachlässig
im Umgang mit diesen Tätern gewesen ist
insofern ihm das jetzt als Verdienst
aufzulegen oder anzuerkennen dass er
nach 2010 dort
mehr Konsequenz gezeigt hat als seine
Vorgänger das fällt mir tatsächlich
schwer so gesehen dass dieser 30
Dezember 31 dezember 2022 sicher ein
ambivalent besetzter Tag der gerade bei
dem betroffenen eben auch dunkle düstere
Erinnerungen Erinnerungen Weg der umso
mehr Dank an Sie dass Sie sich für ein
Gespräch zur Verfügung gestellt haben
danke Herr Katsch
danke schön ja vertiefen wir dieses
wichtige Thema das auch an Benedikt
Todestag seinen Platz finden muss noch
mit dem Leiter der katholischen
kirchenredaktion hier im ZDF Jürgen
Erbacher ich grüße dich
Josef Ratzinger muss man ja bedenken hat
insgesamt 36 Jahre lang Verantwortung
getragen in der kirchlichen Hierarchie
erst als Bischof dann als perfekt später
als Papst er hat sich denn seine Haltung
zum sexuellen Missbrauch zur
sexualisierten Gewalt in der Kirche
entwickelt
ich glaube er musste einen Weg
zurücklegen er konnte sich als Josef
Ratzinger als junger Theologe Erzbischof
glaube ich nicht vorstellen dass
Kleriker solche Taten verüben er musste
erst lernen in diesen Abgrund zu schauen
und ihn auch zu akzeptieren als
perfekter Glaubenskongregation es ist ja
auch angeklungen hat er dann durchaus
begonnen zu handeln unter Johannes Paul
II war das allerdings auch gar nicht so
richtig möglich da wurde vieles
blockiert von den Seilschaften auch im
Vatikan als er Papst wurde hat er dann
angefangen er hat manches aufs Gleis
gesetzt aber in der letzten Konsequenz
gerade an die Strukturen Rand zu gehen
die Missbrauch und Vertuschung möglich
gemacht haben das ist ihm nicht gelungen
aber auch er glaube ich als er dann am
Ende ja auch zurückgetreten ist hat
diese Widerstände gespürt in der
römischen Zentralverwaltung und im
eposkopath weltweit und deshalb ist er
glaube ich auch nicht sehr weit gekommen
sagen ja sogar Benedikt Ratzinger früher
auch als perfekte glaubenssituation sei
einer der ersten im Vatikan gewesen die
überhaupt Leid der Opfer wahrgenommen
hätten er hat ja als Paar später auf
seinen Auslandsreisen immer wieder auch
Missbrauchsopfer getroffen aber zuletzt
gerade in den letzten Monaten stand ja
doch da als eine ja dem das Ansehen der
Kirche vielleicht auch sein eigenes
Ansehen wichtiger war als das Leid der
Opfer wie ist dieser Widerspruch zu
erklären ich glaube da ist benedikt der
16 ähnlich gewesen wie viele andere
Kirchen hier reichen die geben
vielleicht eine Verantwortung der
Institution zu aber persönlich eine
Verantwortung wollen sie nicht
übernehmen dass das am Ende der
Institution wirklich schadet das sehen
sie nicht ich glaube aber wenn man sieht
2010 als der Missbrauchskandal auch in
Deutschland aufkam in vielen anderen
Ländern haben viele Kirchenleute gesagt
das ist eine Medienkampagne oder sogar
von Geschwätz gesprochen da hat er ganz
klar gesagt Leute Stopp nein das ist ein
Problem der Kirche das müssen wir aus
ihnen von innen herauslösen und hier
Veränderungen anstreben also da muss man
ihn glaube ich schon auch sehr
differenziert sehen die sexualisierte
Gewalt in der katholischen Kirche seit
Jahren ein großes Thema und auch an
diesem Tag dürfen wir es nicht
ignorieren wenn es um die bilanze des
Lebenswerkes von Josef Ratzinger
Benedikt dem 16 geht Jürgen wir sprechen
uns gleich noch einmal ja was am 11
februar 2013 passiert ist das kam für
die Welt insbesondere für die
katholische ja überraschend denn an dem
Tag erklärte Benedikt vor den
versammelten Kardinälen seinen Rücktritt
es war das erste Mal seit über 700
Jahren dass ein amtierender Papst
freiwillig auf sein Amt verzichtet hat
er wolle für die Welt künftig verborgen
bleiben hatte Benedikt angekündigt
zurückgezogen leben hinter den Mauern
des Klosters Martha eclesia in den
vatikanischen Gärten aber dann kam es
doch etwas anders
februar 2013 die Sensation im Vatikan
völlig unerwartet verkündet Papst
Benedikt seinen Rücktritt
zu groß waren die Aufgaben der
Kirchenführung angesichts der
Missbrauchskandale und andere Affären in
der Kurie kurz nach seiner Ankündigung
gelobte er seinem Nachfolger Gehorsam
mit der Wahl seines Nachfolgers gab es
neben dem amtierenden Papst franziskus
in der katholischen Kirche einen der
sich selbst den Titel römischer
imitierter Pontifex zugelegt hat einen
der für sich selbst entschieden hat auch
die weiße sudane zu tragen
schon unmittelbar nach der
Rücktrittsankündigung gab es Kritik an
Papst Benedikt sein Vorgänger der
polnische Papst Johannes Paul II habe
sein Amt wie Jesus Christus durch Leiden
und Sterben hindurch bis Golgatha
getragen auch Jesus sei nicht vom Kreuz
gestiegen hieß es
aber genau solche Bilder von
Hinfälligkeit möchte Papst Benedikt
nicht produzieren die Schwäche seines
Vorgängers und das Machtvakuum in der
Endphase seines Pontifikats sollten sich
nicht wiederholen
deshalb bekräftigte der EM irritierte
Papst dass ein Rücktritt freiwillig
gewesen und damit auch kirchenrechtlich
gültig sei für Kirchenreformer eröffnet
sich mit seinem Schritt die Möglichkeit
kirchenrechtlich korrekt mit einem Papst
außer Diensten zu leben
Papst franziskus hatte mit dieser
Konstellation keine Schwierigkeiten er
pflegte eine herzliche Beziehung zu
Papst Benedikt auch wenn sie nicht in
allem einer Meinung waren immer wieder
betont franziskus die Kirche müsse sich
an imitierte Päpste gewöhnen die Gegner
des jetzigen Papstes bedrängten seinen
Vorgänger sich kritisch zu Wort zu
melden zum Beispiel während der
familiensynode der emilitierte Papst
Widerstand dieser Versuchung nicht immer
als einfachen Mönch der zurückgezogen
auf dem Gelände des Vatikan lebt
bezeichnete sich benedikt der 16
sein Bedürfnis theologisch tätig zu
bleiben und zu veröffentlichen löste
aber Irritationen aus er äußerte sich
auch zu den Ursachen des sexuellen
Missbrauchs die er im gesellschaftlichen
Wandel und der sexuellen Revolution der
60er Jahre suchte der emeritierte Papst
hat die versprochene Zurückhaltung nicht
immer eingehalten insgesamt war er aber
mit sich und seine Entscheidung als
Papst zurückzutreten im rheinen
ja holen wir noch eine andere
Perspektive mit in die Nachbetrachtung
aus München ist uns Christian Weissner
zugeschaltet Sprecher der Reformbewegung
wir sind Kirche guten Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend nach Mainz er weiß nur sie
betrachten die katholische Amtskirche
jetzt gerade bei ja Glockengeläut
naturgemäß mit skeptischem Blick was
geht ihnen zuerst durch den Kopf wenn
sie an Benedikt Jahre als Papst denken
ja ich stehe hier vor der Kirche wo
Josef Ratzinger viereinhalb Jahre
Erzbischof von München und Freising war
er hatte es eine schwierige Zeit gehabt
aber ich glaube was wirklich das
entscheidende war er war unter was viele
Menschen enttäuscht hat er war damals
beim Zweiten Vatikanischen Konzil in den
1960er Jahren war er ein Reformer er war
Berater des Kölner kardinales Frings
aber er hatte ich dann sehr sehr schnell
zu einem reaktionären Theologen
entwickelt der dann später Bischof
Erzbischof Kardinal war
glaubenskriegfekt und das ist das
enttäuschende wirklich und das
schwierige für die Kirche das schwierige
aber dass sie hinterlässt er hat
versucht zusammen mit Johannes Paul dem
zweiten das Zweite Vatikanische Konzil
das ist Reform conceal wieder
zurückzudrängen und weil das gewesen ist
sind diese ganzen anderen worüber wir
als gesprochen haben die Vertuschung ist
wirklich dann zu einem großen Makel der
Kirche gewesen das ist wirklich schade
dass es die Kirche nicht geschafft hat
wirklich in die Gegenwart zu kommen das
hat er verhindert
also die Reform Hoffnungen vieler
deutscher Katholiken haben sich unter
Benedikt sicher nicht erfüllt also weder
in Bezug auf mehr Demokratie in der
Kirche noch in der sexualmoralen noch in
Bezug auf die Rolle der Frauen in der
Kirche hatten Sie denn persönlich
überhaupt die Erwartung dass ich unter
Benedikt etwas bewegen würde
nein also so ein Papst gewählt wollte
hatten wir diese Erwartung nicht mehr
weil wir erlebt haben wie lange er mehr
als 20 Jahre als Glaubens perfekt in Rom
tätig gewesen ist und seine Stimme und
seine Bescheidenheit seine persönliche
Bescheidenheit die verdecken aber dass
er da wirklich ein sehr hartes Regiment
geführt hat hat viele Theologen und
Theologen in mundtot gemacht er hat
wirklich die Kirche in eine Sackgasse
geführt und jetzt mit dem Tod wir
wünschen ihm alle Frieden aber jetzt mit
dem Tod ist wirklich eine Ehre dieser
beiden Päpste zusammen zu Ende gegangen
Johannes Paul II und Papst Benedikt
diese Ära ist jetzt zu Ende und ich
hoffe sehr dass mit Papst franziskus ein
neuer Aufbruch im Geiste des Konzils
gelingt das ist die Hoffnung das
Sprechers der kritischen Katholiken
Christian weißner jetzt wie wir hören
bei Glocken geläuft vielleicht auch für
den Verstorbenen Benedikt den 16 in
seiner Heimat hier sind danke nach
München
[Musik]
gerne
ja 2017 da haben die Protestanten 500
Jahre Reformation gefeiert für Josef
Ratzinger aber war das nie ein Grund zum
Feiern er zur Trauer über die
Jahrhunderte alte Spaltung der
Christenheit trotzdem oder gerade
deshalb hat Benedikt einige ökumenische
Akzente gesetzt in seinem Pontifikat er
wolle Schritte zur sichtbaren Einheit
der Christen gehen hatte Benedikt schon
kurz nach seiner Wahl zum Papst gesagt
und gemessen daran am Ende doch viele
Christen in beiden Kirchen enttäuscht
die deutschsprachige evangelische
Christuskirche in Rom nach Johannes Paul
II besucht benedikt der 16 als zweiter
Papst der Geschichte eine
protestantische Kirche er will Zeichen
setzen wo Theologie ins Stocken geraten
ist hören halte viel klagen die Ökumene
sei zum Stillstand gekommen
Vorwürfe gegenseitig
ich denke zuallererst aber was sollten
wir doch dankbar werden das ist so viele
Einheit gibt
trotz vieler Gesten sichtbare
Fortschritte im Dialog zwischen
Katholiken und Protestanten gibt es
unter Benedikt nicht im Gegenteil die
Unterschiede werden stärker betont die
evangelische Kirche ist aus Sicht des
Vatikans keine Kirche nach katholischem
Verständnis so ein Dokument aus dem
Sommer 2007 es führt zur Verhärtung der
Positionen
angesichts der zunehmenden
Säkularisierung der Gesellschaft sieht
er aber keine Alternative zur Ökumene
die Christen müssten mit einer Stimme
sprechen um auch weiter ernst genommen
zu werden
müssen wir wieder Zeugnis geben von den
Maßstäben die Leben zu leben machen
dieser großen
gemeinsamen Aufgabe aller Glaubenden
müssen wir uns mit großer
Entschiedenheit stellen
das Augustinerkloster in Erfurt hier hat
Martin Luther studiert und seine erste
Messe gefeiert ein symbolträchtiger Ort
für die ökumenische Begegnung im
September 2011 im kleinen Kreis würdigt
der Papst Luther und dessen Leidenschaft
für die Gottesfrage manche Beobachter
sprechen gar von einer teilweisen
Rehabilitierung des Reformators
beim anschließenden Gottesdienst
allerdings stellt Benedikt XVI klar
konkrete Fortschritte in der Ökumene
sind so schnell nicht zu erwarten er
habe keine ökumenischen Gastgeschenke
mitgebracht der Papst aus dem Land der
Reformation wollte in der Ökumene
Vorankommen die Gemeinsamkeiten im
Glauben hervorheben nicht das Trennende
betonen doch das Ziel der Einheit der
Kirchen schien am Ende seines
Pontifikats ferner denn je
und einer der 2011 im ehemaligen
Augustinerkloster zu Erfurt Papst
Benedikt persönlich getroffen hat ist
Nikolaus Schneider damals
Ratsvorsitzender der Evangelischen
Kirche in Deutschland guten Abend nach
Essen
schönen guten Abend herr Schneider die
katholische Kirche trauert um ihren
verstorbenen Papa Emeritus was empfindet
heute ein Protestant der in seiner
Kirche Verantwortung getragen hat in
diesen Stunden
der Tod von Papst Benedikt den 16
Weg bei mir Erinnerungen an Begegnungen
mit einem Menschen der so im
persönlichen Umgang
ausgesprochen freundlich war ein sehr
feinsinniger Mensch ein Mensch der auch
sehr wertschätzend mit mir umgegangen
ist er ist aber auch ein Mensch gewesen
der gleichzeitig wenn es um die Kirche
ging doch sehr deutlich und manchmal
auch schroff sein konnte er hat uns
zugemutet dass wir die Aussagen seiner
Kirche die der Glaubenskongregation so
auffassen sollten als würden sie die
Wahrheit des christlichen Glaubens für
alle einfach definieren das war schon
eine ziemliche Herausforderung aber an
diesem Abend soll etwas anderes noch im
Vordergrund stehen nämlich wir hoffen
dass benedikt der 16 nun gehen wird was
wir gemeinsam glauben dass er als Sohn
Josef Ratzinger Sohn und Diener Gottes
nun im Gottes Gegenwart leben kann und
durch den Tod hindurch zum Leben gehört
das wünschen wir Ihnen von Herzen und
gehört ja auch zur Realität dieser Tage
das Katholiken und Protestanten doch das
Trennende in vielen Bereichen erleben
vor allem beim Abendmahl im Gottesdienst
dass sie nicht gemeinsam feiern dürfen
was wünschen sie sich an einem Tag wie
heute für das künftige Zusammenleben von
Christen in diesem Land und auch
weltweit
dass die Schritte der Ökumene die Josef
Ratzinger auch ermöglicht hat etwa in
der
gemeinsamen Erklärung
zurechtfertigungslehre in dem
ökumenischen Gottesdienst wir könnten
einige Zeichen nennen dass die noch ganz
anders wirksam werden dass seine
restaurative Auslegung des Zweiten
Vatikanischen Konzils nicht bestimmend
wird sondern dass das konfessions
Verbindende das in vielen Familien
gelebt wird dass dies denn auch
bestimmen wird gewürdigt wird dass wir
gemeinsam Abendmahl feiern können dass
wir einen gemeinsames Zeugnis für den
Frieden in der Welt geben können so dass
diese Kriege auch ans Ende gebracht
werden dass wir ein gemeinsames Zeugnis
der Liebe Gottes geben können dass wir
auch mit den Dunkelheiten dieser Welt
mit der Armut und dem Hunger ganz anders
umgehen können und dass wir schließlich
auch gemeinsam Abendmahl feiern können
ein kräftiges Zeugnis des Zusammenseins
in dieser Welt und das lieber Herr
Schneider ist sicherlich nicht nur Ihre
persönliche Hoffnung an diesem
Silvestertag 2022 danke für das Gespräch
und Grüße nach Essen
sehr gerne herzlichen Dank
ja benedikt der 16 ist also im Alter von
95 Jahren gestorben am Silvestertag
benannt nach Papst Silvester der im
vierten Jahrhundert die katholische
Kirche regiert hat was passiert
eigentlich wenn ein emeritierter Papst
stirbt der Nachfolger muss ja nicht
gewählt werden es gibt keinen Konklave
im minamuja geht schon und René Severin
klären auf
hier in diesem Kloster Martha erklärsil
verbrachte Papst Benedikt XV die letzten
zehn Jahre seines Lebens weitersgehend
abgeschieden von der Öffentlichkeit hier
hatte er am Mittwoch die kranksalbung
erhalten hier ist der heute morgen
verstorben sein Leichnam wird ab Montag
dem zweiten Januar im Petersdom
aufgebaut das gab der Vatikan bekannt
die Gläubigen sollen sich so
verabschieden können die Details zum
Zutritt zur Dauer der Aufbahrung lässt
der Sprecher des Heiligen Stuhls am
Mittag noch offen am kommenden
Donnerstag dem 5 Januar dann die
Trauerfeier auf dem Petersplatz Papst
franziskus wird der Messe vorstehen auch
das gab der Vatikan heute bekannt schon
im Vorfeld war das vermutet worden auf
Wunsch Benedikt wird die Messe schlicht
ablaufen
da es sich bei Papst Benedikt dem 16
auch um das ehemalige Oberhaupt des
Vatikanstaates handelt erwarten Experten
Staatsgäste aus der ganzen Welt seine
letzte Ruhe wird er dann wohl in den
Grotten des Petersdoms finden an dem
ehemaligen Platz von Papst Johannes Paul
dem zweiten vor dessen Umbettung so
hatte es sich der Verstorbene Papst
Benedikt gewünscht
und das alles wird am Donnerstag
geschehen wenn Papst franziskus die
Totenmesse für Benedikt leitet fragen
wir nach bei Andreas Postel im
nächtlichen Rom Andreas wie nimmt man
denn rund um den Petersplatz zur Stunde
Anteil und wie geht es in den nächsten
Tagen jetzt konkret weiter
Rom ist geprägt heute von einem
doppelten Abschied der Abschied vom
alten Jahr was auch für Benedikt
sicherlich nicht einfach war und vom
Abschied vom Papst vom ehemaligen Papst
Benedikt im 16 der eben heute hier in
Rom verstorben ist es wird in den
nächsten Tagen sehr still werden denke
ich um den Petersplatz das war heute
auch schon zu merken als dann die Abend
Vesper hier stattfand im Petersdom mit
Papst franziskus der das alte Jahr
verabschiedet hat und viele Gläubigen
sich hier von Papst Benedikt auch im
Gebet bereits verabschiedet haben und in
den nächsten Tagen am 2.1 wir haben es
gerade im Beitrag gehört mit der
Leichnam von Papst Benedikt dem
emeritierten aufgebaut werden im
Petersdom und am Donnerstag dann wird
die Toten Messe gehalten werden auf dem
Petersplatz mit sehr sehr vielen
Gläubigen die hier erwartet werden und
dann wird es die Trauerfeier geben und
die Beisetzung die dann hier auf dem
Petersplatz zelebriert werden wird von
Papst franziskus noch also wie sie sagen
jetzt das relativ ruhig in der Ewigen
Stadt aber das wird sich ändern hin zum
Donnerstag wenn das Requiem für Benedikt
stattfindet um halb zehn beginnen wird
live hier im ZDF übrigens zu sehen ja
und von der Wahlheimat Josef Ratzingers
gehen wir einmal in die angestammte
Heimat nämlich nach München zu Stefan
leifert Stefan ja wie trauert Bayern und
die werden Ihnen seine bayerischen
Landsleute in Erinnerung behalten
ja auch der bayerische Blick auf diesen
Papst wird ein ambivalenter bleiben das
klang sogar auch gerade in der
silvesterpredigt von Kardinal Marx hier
in Münchener Dom an da ist auf der einen
Seite der Tiefe bayerische stolz auf
diese jahrhundertfigur auf einen
Ausnahme Theologen ein Stolz der 2006
sein Höhepunkt fand als Benedikt beim
bejubelten Besuch hier noch einmal in
Bayern zu Gast war auf der anderen Seite
wird Josef Ratzinger aber hier auch in
Erinnerung bleiben als Symbolfigur für
das Versagen und für das Scheitern der
katholischen Kirche im Umgang mit den
sexuellen Verbrechen ihrer Priester das
Benedikt bis zum Schluss nicht bereit
war auch persönliches Fehlverhalten
während seiner Münchner Amtszeit als
Erzbischof hier einzugestehen
hinterlässt bei vielen Gläubigen in
Bayern eine tiefe Enttäuschung und eine
Wunde die nun nicht mehr zu heilen ist
am Dienstag gibt es hier in Münchner Dom
ein Requiem und am Donnerstag wird dann
eine stattliche bayerische Delegation zu
Beerdigung von Papst Benedikt nach Rom
reisen
wir trauern um unseren bayerischen Papst
sagt Ministerpräsident Markus Söder also
im Freistaat wird heute mindestens
bildhaft gesprochen Halbmast geflagte
Stefan Leifheit danke für diese
Eindrücke ins Dunkle München und wir
Liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
runden den Rückblick auf das Lebenswerk
von Benedikt im 16 jetzt noch einmal ab
mit Jürgen Erbacher der das Pontifikat
des deutschen Papstes aus nächster Nähe
beobachtet hat vor allem in den Jahren
2005 bis 13 Jürgen abschließend was ist
für dich das Bleibende Erbe Benedikt des
16 wie hat er seine Kirche nachhaltig
geprägt was mit Sicherheit bleiben wird
ist der Rücktritt er ist historisch und
hat das Papst nachhaltig verändert
enzeralisiert auch geerdet und wir haben
jetzt auch viel Kritisches über seine
Theologie gehört über seinen wirken als
Theologe und Papst das wird auch bleiben
und alle die sich Reformen wünschen die
werden sich damit auseinandersetzen
müssen denn das ist auch eine Strömung
innerhalb der katholischen Kirche die
wenn man das weltweit betrachtet von
vielen auch vertreten wäre das Afrika
hörte man heute zum Beispiel hier ist
ein großer theologischer Lehrer
gestorben und damit wird man sich
auseinandersetzen müssen am Ende ist es
auch schon angeklungen Benedikt XVI ein
übergangspapst in seinem Pontifikat
haben sich glaube ich ganz viele
Probleme die sich über Jahrzehnte
aufgestellt aufgestaut haben
brennglasartig verdeutlicht und haben am
Ende den Weg frei gemacht für einen
Papst ganz anderen Typs nämlich
Franziskus und auch ein vielstimmiges
Echo auf diese Todesnachricht auf das
Ableben von Benedikt dem 16 das
sicherlich die nächsten Tage noch
bestimmen wird und Tiefe in die kommende
Woche hineinwirken wird bis zum Requiem
an dem wir uns dann in Rom Wiedersehen
danke für den Moment und deinen Besuch
hier im Studium bitte
ja die Erwartungshaltung bei seiner Wahl
zum Papste war groß doch viele
Hoffnungen die Katholiken gerade in
Deutschland mit seinem Pontifikat
verbunden haben sind doch unerfüllt
geblieben weitreichendere Formen konnte
oder wollte Benedikt nicht umsetzen doch
bei aller Kritik mit Josef Ratzinger
verliert die katholische Kirche einen
ihrer größten Theologen der Gegenwart
das war unser zdf-spezial ich danke
Ihnen für Ihr Interesse und noch einen
guten Jahresausklang ein guten Abend
hier aus Mainz wir verabschieden uns
tschüss auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]